EVERYONE JUMPED ON TO "GUITAR
HERO" BECAUSE WE ALL WANTED TO
ACT LIKE WE COULD PLAY GUITAR,
NONE OF US COULD.
LET'S SEE IF T-PAIN CAN --
>> NO, MA'AM.
♪
>> OH,, OH!
THE PIG IS IN THERE, OKAY.
♪
>> GOT TO SCRATCH THAT PIGGY.
>> I'M KILNG THIS.
♪
>> OH, IT'S DOWN!
OH!
OKAY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW MY OWN SONG
ANYMORE.
♪
>> DID WE CALIBRATE THIS?
I DON'T THINK WE CALIBRATED
THIS.
>> YOU GOT IT.
♪
>> OKAY, YOU GOT IT.
HEY, HEY.
>> OH MY GOD!
♪
OH M MY GOD!
WHO MADE THIS?
♪
>> MY BUDDY BEN.
>> BEN?
OH!
HOW YOU EVEN DO THAT?
♪
THAT'S NOT GOING TO -- WE DIDN'T
SAL GREAT THAT.
I DON'T THINK WE CALIBRATED
THAT.
♪
>> THE NUMBER ONE ENEMY OF EVERY
"GUITAR HERO" PLAYER.
>> SEE, THE BAD THING IS I CAN
PLAY REAL GUITAR, AND THIS IS
NOT HELPING ME AT ALL.
♪
>>>> OH, I'MUT.
YEAH, THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
♪
DON'T TWIST THE SCREEN, I'M
LOOKING AT THE SCREEN, YOU GOT
TO SWITCH IT!
♪
THANK YOU.
>> I'VE GOT TO SAY, YOU LOOK
GREAT, THOUGH.
♪
>> COULDN'T GET THAT AT ALL.
I'M TERRIBLE AT PINKY STUFF.
YOU SEE WHAT I DID THERE?
IT'S A FAMILY JOKE.
♪
>> THE PINKY STRETCH IS HARD.
EVEN ACROSS A KEYBOARD.
>> OH!
♪
>> I KNOW GUYS THAT PLAY WITH
ONLY TWO FINGERS.
>> WHAT?
>> YEAH, SEE, NOW YOU'RE JUST
TRYING TO EMBARRASS ME.
♪
>> OH!
WHAT IS THIS?
WHAT -- OH, COME ON.
OH, COME ON.
COME ON!
♪
>> OKAY, I DON'T EVEN KNOW MY
OWN SONG ANYMORE.
>> YOU KNOW, THE WAY HE'S MOVING
HIS FINGERS, HE BARELY PICKS HIS
FINGERS UP.
>> OH, THIS IS -- THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> IT'S LIKE BUTTER OVER THERE.
♪
>> OH, THAT ACTUALLY WORKED
I'VE NEVER ACTUALLY DONE THAT
BEFORE.
♪
>> OH, NICE!
>> I CAN'T WRAP MY HEAD AROUND
THESE SPLITS.
THESE ARE CRAZY.
♪
>> LISTEN.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THIS SHOWS THE
DIFFERENT KIND OF SKILL SETS
THAT IT TAKES TO PLAY ALL
DIFFERENT KINDS OF GAMES.
I KNOW A LOT OF TIMES WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT GAMING, WE ALWAYS
CHECK OUT MOBAS OR MPSs OR
BATTLE YALS.
BUT THIS IN ITSELF --
>> THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
>> THIS IS A LOT.
>> THIS IS OUT OF CONTROL.
THINK THIS IS AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE